one question I
have I don't know about you but for me
unlike with the Soviet
Union and I know I was born there but
even outside of that the cultural
Gap the the the loss in Translation the
communication gap between China and the
United States seems to be much greater
than that of what was the former Soviet
Union and the United States
I see two cultures intermingling and
communicating as one of the ways to
deescalate future
conflict it's an interesting question I
mean at a sort of an abstract
theoretical level my argument is that
great Powers Act according to realist
dictates and they understand those
realist dictates and uh that could lead
to cooperation or it can lead to to uh
War uh it depends uh I would say just in
the case of the Soviets a lot of people
describe the Cold War as an ideological
competition above all else it's was
communism
versus liberal democracy or communism
versus liberal capitalism whatever uh I
actually don't believe that I I believe
the Soviets were uh realists to the poor
uh I believe Stalin was a realist par
Excellence uh and that ideology did not
matter much in Stalin's foreign policy
and I believe if you look at Soviet
foreign policy uh after World War II you
know throughout the Cold War they were
realists to the core uh and uh and I
think in those days the Americans were
realists right uh a lot of liberal
ideology floating around out there but
the Americans were realists and I think
one of the reasons you avoided uh a
shooting match between the United States
and the Soviet Union from 47 to uh
89 uh was because both sides I think uh
understood basic balance of power
logic us China competition is somewhat
different first of all the Chinese are
realist to the core uh I've spent a lot
of time in China I basically have rock
and roll I'm basically a rock and roll
star in China
uh the Chinese you're kind of a big deal
in China I love it the Chinese are my
kind of people yeah they're realist
right they speak my language yeah it's
the United States that is not very
realist American leaders uh have a very
powerful liberal bent and tend not to
see the world in realist terms I Believe
by the way just going back to our
discussion of NATO expansion I think our
inability to understand that NATO
expansion was anathema to the Soviet to
the Russians was doing large part to the
fact that we just during the unipolar
moment didn't think of international
politics from a realist perspective and
didn't respect anyone who thought about
International politics from a realist
perspective if those various American
administrations starting with the
Clinton administration had put their
realest hat on they would have
understood that NATO expansion into
Ukraine was not a good idea but we had
this thoroughly liberal view of the
world that dominated our thinking and
it's gone away somewhat since we've
moved into multipolarity but not
completely and uh this makes me a little
nervous right to pick up on your point I
mean the United States is thinking about
the world in ways that are somewhat
different than the Chinese who are real
is par Excellence so that's fascinating
so the Chinese are
pragmatic uh about thinking of the world
in
um as a competition of military Powers
all the ways in which he described the
realist perspective so that I mean
that's a that's a that's a hopeful thing
right
if uh we can achieve stability and a
balance of powers through that military
competition yeah I I actually think
that's right I think if the United
States just let me talk a little bit
about the United States to get at the
issue you're raising if the United
States pursues a smart containment
strategy mhm given what you just said
and I said about the Chinese I think we
will avoid war the problem with the
Americans is it's not just the
liberalism it's the possibility that we
will pursue a rollback
policy in other words during the Cold
War uh we pursued containment it was
whenever anybody talked about American
Grand strategy towards the Soviet Union
was Containment containment containment
we now know from the his historical
record that the United States was not
only pursuing containment it was
pursuing roll back we were trying to
roll back Soviet power to put it bluntly
we were trying to wreck the Soviet Union
okay and I would not be surprised moving
forward with regard to China if the
United States pursues a serious roll
back policy and uh so you're saying
throughout history United States was
always doing that always where's that
from why why can't we respect the power
of other nations because they may be a
threat to us we well I mean you don't
look you don't respect the power of
other nations you fear the power of
other nations well fear and respect the
Nextdoor neighbors depending on the
neighborhood you're living in but I I
just mean it's it could be very
counterproductive to try because if you
can empathize with their if if you
assume their rational actors you trying
to roll back will
create
um would lean into the
uncertainty of potential conflict so you
want to avoid the uncertainty of
potential conflict caution right well
yes and no look your point is you want
to empathize you want to be able to put
yourself in the shoes of the other side
yes I agree 100% but with that right
it's very important if you're a first
class strategist to be able to do that
but at the same time there is this
competition for power taking place and
what you want to do is maximize how much
power you have relative to the other
side and the other side wants to
maximize how much power it has relative
to you so you have this competition for
power right uh that's taking place all
the time and that's taking place at the
same time you want to have empathy or
you want to be able to put yourself in
the shoes of the other side so those two
things kind of go together right it just
feels less threatening to build up your
thing
versus try to hurt the other person's
thing the other group's thing right but
if you build up your own power you were
building up your capability to hurt the
other side right but like you I guess
you don't rattle the saber just just
work on manufacturing
Sabers well that I agree with I I think
that you know the United States you know
uh wants to make sure it has a big stick
in East Asia for purposes of containing
China and avoiding a war right again I
want to be clear I'm not advocating uh
that we start world war three but the
point is you want to have a big stick
and you want to make sure that you don't
overstep your bounds in terms of using
that big stick this is the danger with
rollback right that you get too
aggressive and you precipitate a war
right and you also just have to be very
careful what you say and to go back to
your favorite argument you want to be
able to have empathy or put yourself in
uh the shoes of the other side because
if you do something you want to think
smartly about what that other side how
that other side is going to see your
action and how they're going to react
right and and mostly focus on the
carrots have a giant stick laying around
but never mention it just focus on the
carrots well occasionally you have to
mention the stick right no everyone
knows the stick is there there is some
truth in that right Ian yeah uh but you
know and words matter a lot it feels you
know this uh current President Biden's
meeting with Xi Jinping and I think the
wars exchanged there are really
important I have a notion the leaders
can stop Wars just as much as they can
start
wars well leaders matter there's no
question about that no question but just
on on rhetoric you want to remember that
Putin has on more than one occasion very
subtly rattled the nuclear sword oh yeah
and it has been very effective yeah
because Joe Biden has paid attention and
Joe Biden wants to make sure we don't
end up in a thermonuclear war and thank
goodness uh he's thinking that way so
all Putin has to do is mention the
possibility of nuclear war just to go
back to Taiwan you know a switch areas
of the world if you're interested in
containing China and you're interested
in Cur and let's go back to those
various scenarios where the Chinese win
we win Chinese win but they do it at a
costly at Great cost one could
argue that that discussion that I laid
out before didn't take into account
nuclear weapons and all President Biden
or any of his successors has to do is
just very subtly uh rattle uh or or or
or or employ the nuclear threat you know
uh and just sort of remind the Chinese
that you know you start a war over
Taiwan it could easily escalate into a
nuclear war you want to understand we
both have nuclear weapons and if either
one of us is put into a desperate
situation we may turn to those nuclear
weapons and oh by the way XI jingping
you want to understand that we're out
here in the water and using nuclear
weapons in the water it's not that uh
it's not the same as using War uh
nuclear weapons on land so we may very
well use them I'm not saying we will but
anyway a little saber rattling yeah
right